President Trump is keeping up his
attacks on the Justice Department's
investigation into Russia's alleged
meddling in the u.s. presidential
election on Friday mr. Trump took aim at
Deputy Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
who is supervising the investigation and
questioned his integrity
Errol Barnett is in our Washington
newsroom with the latest Erol good
morning good morning president Trump
tried to cap what the White House Calls
Workforce Development week with a show
of productivity but the cloud the
president feels is hanging over his
administration shows no signs of
clearing and by venting his frustrations
online mr. Trump may be making political
and legal headwinds worse strengthening
the policy of the United States toward
Cuba in Miami Friday President Trump
delivered another campaign promise
chipping away at an Obama era policy
which enhanced ties between the u.s. and
Cuba I am canceling the last
administration's completely one-sided
deal with Cuba but he surprised many
earlier in the day confirming a report
that he is the subject of an
investigation into potential obstruction
of justice the president tweeted I am
being investigated for firing the FBI
director by the man who told me to fire
the FBI director witch-hunt special
counsel Muller may be fired only for
good cause and I am required to put that
cause in writing mr. Trump appears
frustrated at Deputy Attorney General
rod Rosenstein who along with Attorney
General Jeff Sessions recommended James
Comey be dismissed
the president previously said he was
going to do it anyway
he made a recommendation but regardless
of recommendation I was going to fire
call me Trump cited Russia as a reason
for the move and when Comey revealed he
had detailed memos of their private
meetings Rosenstein appointed Robert
Muller as special counsel president
Trump initially praised Muller but now
calls ongoing investigations witch hunts
while decrying leaks constitutional law
professor Jonathan Turley I can't
imagine the Special Counsel completing
the
investigation without hearing the
testimony of the Deputy Attorney General
so once you think that you may be a
witness it's time for you to remove
yourself on Friday Democratic and
Republican senators voice support for
Mullah I think it would be an absolute
disaster if the president were to move
forward and fire the special counsel Bob
Muller is a good and honorable man and
so that I hope he will focus on his
specific assignment and not allow allow
it to turn into just a far-ranging
fishing expedition now it's clear legal
risks are mounting for the president's
associates as well
CBS obtained a letter sent by the Trump
campaigns executive director two
staffers instructing them to preserve
any and all documents related to their
work also Vice President Mike Pence who
was in charge of the transition hired a
personal lawyer describing it to
reporters as very routine Anthony Errol
Barnett thanks Harold